en 2013 une collaboration de chercheurs
de lucie san diego de cornell et de
facebook publie les résultats
stupéfiants en modifiant légèrement
l'algorithme de newsfeed de facebook ils
ont affecté l'humeur d'une centaine de
milliers d'individus
jusque là on a parlé du problème de la
morale d il ya de manière assez
abstraite et vous avez peut-être eu
l'impression qu'il s'agissait d'un
problème pour les futures générations
et bien aujourd'hui et dans les vidéos à
venir on va voir que non le problème de
la morale désir est un problème urgent
qui a des conséquences majeures dès
aujourd'hui en fait je vais même essayer
de vous convaincre que ça fait déjà
plusieurs années que l'entité la plus
puissante du monde est unir alors ça
peut paraître assez grandiloquent comme
l'affirmation qu'est ce que peut bien
signifier l'entité la plus puissante du
monde
eh bien je ne prétends pas qu'il
s'agisse d'un concept rigoureux mais
intuitivement une entité va avoir
beaucoup de pouvoir si un petit
changement dans son comportement a
rapidement des conséquences très
différentes et ça c'est crucial pour un
conséquentialiste pour rappel le
conséquentialiste mme est une
philosophie morale qui considère que les
actions moralement bonne sont celles qui
conduisent à des conséquences désirable
plus encore si une action à conduire une
conséquence très désirable alors que
toutes les actions alternatives
conduisent à de très mauvaises
conséquences alors effectuer l'action à
sera un énorme devoir moral même si
l'action a et coûteuse par ailleurs on
peut rendre cette idée un peu plus
formel imaginons que nous disposions
d'une certaine ressources erp qui
pourrait être le travail que l'on est
capable de fournir ou la dépense
énergétique de notre solution
technologique ou le budget qu'on est
prêt à dépenser
supposons que plus on dépense de
ressources r plus les conséquences
morales sont désirables
sauf que dépenser la ressource a aussi
un coût individuel
typiquement un travail et ça me fatigue
et parfois j'ai juste envie de dormir
dès lors on peut quantifier le devoir
moral du conséquentialiste en regardant
comment la dépense de la ressource r
affecte les conséquences morales versus
comment cette dépense additionnelle avec
le coût individuel en maths on parlerait
de la dérive et des conséquences par les
ressources versus l'utilité marginale de
la ressource
lorsque la première dérivés est bien
plus grande que la seconde en valeur
absolue il s'agira alors d'un devoir
moral important que de dépenser cette
ressource et c'est pour ça que monsieur
fille aime bien introduire l'idée d'un
bout
pour mettre en exergue nos devoirs
moraux si l'effort ne consiste qu'à
appuyer sur un bouton
tout coût individuel disparaît alors et
on est alors confronté à un dilemme
purement moral et je vois envoie
d'ailleurs versé nombreuses excellentes
vidéo pour plus de détails
ce type de raisonnement permet également
de mieux prioriser les batailles moral
sachant que nos ressources erp sont
limitées selon le conséquentialiste mme
il nous faut optimiser la gestion de nos
ressources
imaginons ainsi deux causes c1 et c2 et
supposons qu'on dispose d'une unité de
ressources additionnelles à investir
pour savoir s'il vaut mieux investir
dans ses seins ou ces deux il s'agit
alors de comparer l'impact d'une unité
de ressources sur la qos et 1 et celle
sur la cause ces deux là où l'impact est
plus important elle là où il faudra
investir l'unité de ressources en
question qui plus est selon le
conséquentialiste il sera une faute
morale que de l'investir mauvais endroit
tout ceci peut sembler assez technique
il peut sembler difficile d'arriver à
des réponse univoque
oui comme on en a déjà parlé avec
monsieur fille être un conséquentialiste
morale c'est très difficile ne serait ce
parce qu'il faut être capable d'estimer
les conséquences de nos actions
mais comme le dirait john key mieux vaut
une réponse approximative à la bonne
question qu'une réponse exacte à la
mauvaise question en particulier pour un
conséquentialiste il s'agira d'un devoir
moral préalable que de déterminer
quelles sont les actions qui pour une
unité de ressources données auront le
plus d'impact bénéfique
c'est d'ailleurs cette ligne qui a suivi
le mouvement effective altruisme ou
l'association guy noël qui cherche
notamment à quantifier la bonne
utilisation des dons par différentes
charité j'en profite aussi pour vivement
recommandé les excellents podcast
anglophone de julia ghallef ou 2 et
iphone os qui sont dans cet état
d'esprit
malheureusement pour les conséquences ya
liste en pratique dans les débats moraux
ce genre de calcul délicat et souvent
très secondaire pouvoir inexistant et on
a tendance à se contenter de
confrontation de principes
déontologiques
bref pour un conséquentialiste si une
idée a beaucoup de pouvoir c'est à dire
si elle peut provoquer beaucoup de bien
avec peu d'efforts alors il s'agira pour
elle d'un devoir moral important que de
faire cet effort est l inverse si on
sait qu'une entité a beaucoup de
pouvoirs mais n'effectuent pas cet
effort
alors il s'agira d'une priorité morale
que d'encourager cette
et à faire cet effort comme le dirait
l'oncle de spider man de grand pouvoir
implique de grandes responsabilités
[Musique]
alors ça c'est précisément le cas de
ziad des géants du web en particulier
lié à de newsfeed de facebook comme le
montre d'ailleurs la publication de
facebook
ce que les chercheurs ont fait c'est
d'abord choisir une métrique de la joie
ou de la colère des postes facebook même
si cette métrique n'est pas idéal on
peut tout de même raisonnablement
supposer que les individus dont les
postes facebook sont plus joyeux sont
aussi des individus plus voyons ensuite
les chercheurs ont testé les effets d'un
petit changement de l'ia en charge des
news feeds sur l'humeur des utilisateurs
facebook
ils ont ainsi choisi 155 mille
utilisateurs au hasard et ont divisé
aléatoirement ses utilisateurs en trois
groupes pour le groupe de contrôle n'ont
pas changé liés à des news feeds pour le
second ils ont dit à l'ia de promouvoir
des postes joyeux et pour le troisième
groupe
ils lui ont dit de promouvoir des postes
négative une semaine plus tard
comme on pouvait peut-être aussi
attendre les individus du second groupe
se sont mis à éclair des postes plus
joyeux tandis que ceux du troisième
groupe se sont mis à écrire des postes
plus négatif lié à de facebook avaient
influencer l'humeur de centaines de
milliers d'individus
si les résultats sont bien
statistiquement significatifs au sens de
la paix va lui il faut toutefois
rajouter que l'effet n'est pas énorme
mais là encore ce n'est pas si
surprenant
on ne change pas complètement d'humeur
d'une semaine à l'autre
par contre on peut vraiment se demander
ce qu'il en serait si ce changement de
l'humeur des postes auxquels on est
exposé durer plusieurs mois ou plusieurs
années
de façon plus générale s'il y a de
facebook cherché à promouvoir la bonne
humeur et disons les critiques
constructives plutôt que les insultes et
le hooliganisme politique
il pourrait alors avoir un impact global
et ainsi toucher non pas 100 noms
peuvent ils n'ont pas un million mais
des milliards d'individus et le plus
remarquable c'est que ce changement de
comportement de l'ia de facebook
pourrait correspondre à un coût minime
pour facebook
bref pour le conséquentialiste liées à
de facebook est un pouvoir énorme un
pouvoir plus grand que celui de tous tu
mens et de grand pouvoir implique de
grandes responsabilités
plus tard
parce qu'il pense pas
alors cet argument conséquentialiste
vous choque peut-être vous vous dites
peut-être que plutôt que de promouvoir
les critiques constructives et la bonne
humeur
il y adeux facebook devrait être neutre
sauf que la neutralité c'est un concept
complexe mais surtout le problème avec
cette approche c'est surtout que les
utilisateurs de facebook préfère avoir
un incident biaisé et du coup enlever
toute personnalisation du newsfeed
pourrait avoir un coup majeur pour
facebook et pour les utilisateurs de
facebook
et ça en termes conséquentialiste c'est
pas cool puisque ça serait au détriment
des utilisateurs facebook mais en plus
ça serait difficile de convaincre
facebook qu'il s'agit là d'un gros
devoir moral pour facebook puisque ça
impliquerait également un énorme coût
individuel
bref en termes conséquentialiste la
neutralité de facebook ne me semble pas
forcément très justifiable même si je me
trompe peut-être dans quelques
conséquentialiste alors facebook on aime
bien taper dessus
ceci étant dit il me semble qu'il
pourrait y avoir une il ya encore plus
puissante que celle de facebook à savoir
l'ia de youtube en particulier lia qui
recommande telle ou telle vidéo à tel ou
tel utilisateur
on a tous fait l'expérience vous
commencez par une vidéo random à 20
heures et vous enchaîner avec une autre
vidéo et tout à coup il est 3h du matin
et vous regardez maintenant un truc
super bizarre
et puis deux ans plus tard vous faites
partie de communautés dont vous ne
suspects et même pas l'existence deux
ans plus tôt alors parfois cette spirale
est pour le mieux et si vous êtes ici
sur scène ce rôle vous connaissez sans
doute l'incroyable communauté de
vulgarisateur notamment autour du café
des sciences
mais comme vous le savez sans doute il
ya aussi d'autres spirale - raisonnée
qui peuvent conduire à toutes sortes de
théories conspirationnistes paranormal
ou pseudo scientifique ou encore à des
idéologies extrémistes qui promeuvent la
haine envers certains groupes sociaux
les esthéticiens qui cherche à lutter
contre la montée de ces mouvements
pseudo scientifiques disent
régulièrement qu'il est important pour
eux d'être sur youtube pour occuper le
terrain alors certes je pense perso
qu'il faut en effet beaucoup plus de
vidéos scientifique en quantité et en
qualité sur youtube
mais je pense aussi qu'il y a en fait
déjà énormément de quantité et de
qualité sur youtube
dès lors pour occuper le terrain il faut
il suffit que youtube promeuvent ces
vidéos qui existe déjà pour la promotion
de la rationalité et des sciences les
créateurs notamment les nouveaux
créateurs dont fait qu'un pouvoirs très
limités
le vrai pouvoir d' influence il
appartient à lire de youtube
si elle veut promouvoir une vidéo elle
le peut comme personne d'autre
d'ailleurs ce fut le cas de cinq forums
si ma chaîne a maintenant la chance
d'être vus par des dizaines de milliers
parfois même des centaines de milliers
d'entre vous c'est essentiellement grâce
à lla de youtube qui le 20 juillet 2016
c'est tout est commise à promouvoir mes
vidéos elle en a remis une couche
le 14 novembre 2016 or de nos jours nous
regardons plus de vidéos youtube que
nous ne faisons de recherche sur google
autrement dit il ya de youtube nous
fournit bien plus de réponses que nous
nous en faisons ainsi notre
compréhension du monde est fortement
biaisé parce que l'ia de youtube nous
montre pour le meilleur comme pour le
pire
imaginez maintenant qu'il y ait un
bouton devant vous si vous l'appuyer lié
à cherchera alors à promouvoir les vidéo
intelligente et raisonnée et à moins
partager celles qui poussent à la haine
et aux théories conspirationnistes
est-ce que vous appuyez dessus avant de
revenir vos questions quelques annonces
je serai à paris le 30 juin avec
monsieur fille on vous parlera de la
mort dans un café parisien d'inscrire
ces organisé par action française de
transhumanisme et voilà on va essayer de
défendre encore cette idée sur laquelle
la mort c'est quand même un truc pas
cool ça serait bien temps de pouvoir ne
pas vieillir ça serait cool et j'annonce
aussi que je serai au palais de la
découverte le 7 juillet à 16h pour vous
parler du démon de ceux qui connaissent
un petit peu puisque c'est le chapitre 7
de mon livre ce sera notamment pour vous
l'occasion de visiter le palais de la
découverte notamment cette nouvelle
section qui a été ouverte auprès des
couleurs qui correspond à l'informatique
la fois j'étais revenu sur l'épisode sur
les cinq scénarios catastrophes causées
par une intelligence artificielle zai de
dos me fait remarquer que j'ai parlé
uniquement de disto pied pas d'utopie et
du coup la question qui se pose c'est
est-ce que nos copies quand même assez
possible ou presque des cures à une sur
sa fille à deux niveaux humain on risque
vraiment tous d'y passer
alors tout d'abord assez intéressant de
voir que notamment les scénarios 3 et 5
au début tout se passe bien et que tout
finisse par bien se passer et que les
maladies soient tous ce soit tout
soigner que et bien les biens de base
accès pour tous des humains et que on
est même accès à à plein de vie
associative en face tous les projets et
fascinant qu'on a envie de faire et on
développe de plus en plus de
divertissement de plus en plus élaborées
depuis n'ont plus besoin fun je pense
qu'une utopie est tout à fait possible
mais en mobilisant la question en fait
ce serait plutôt de savoir est ce que
une utopie ou en tout cas un monde qui
ne disparaît pas est plausible et je
dois bien dire que avant la
d'avoir travaillé on peut sur ces
dernières vidéos j'étais relativement
confiante à ce danger mais il suffit de
régler après ce sera vous est en fait en
préparant ses vidéos je me suis rendu
compte que le danger je l'avais
largement sous-estimées évidemment il ya
deux choses que je pense avoir vraiment
sous estimé le premier c'est les tous
les risques potentiels je pense qu'avec
ces scénarios on voit bien qu'il ya
beaucoup de beaucoup de risques beaucoup
de causes possibles
beaucoup de façons pour que les choses
aillent mal aujourd'hui encore des
milliards d'euros qui sont investis dans
la recherche sur créer des robots juste
pour tuer moi ça me fait vraiment
flipper donc voilà il ya beaucoup de
risques et je pense avoir sous-estimé
largement c'est risquer un autre truc
que je pense avoir sous-estimé c'est la
probabilité qui les unit à deux niveaux
humain dans un avenir pas si lointain
certes j'ai tendance à penser avant ces
vidéos que bon on avait plusieurs
décennies devant nous du coup on peut
peut vraiment prendre le temps de
recherche bien pensé le problème mais si
le problème est et dans 5 ans il ya des
chercheurs en ia qui pensent que il
pourrait avoir une ou deux niveaux
humain dans cinq ans si le premier dans
cinq ans on n'est pas du tout prêt
n'aimait vraiment aujourd'hui je prenais
vraiment absolument pas près
qu'aujourd'hui s'il ya quelqu'un qui a
les pieds tous les ingrédients en
sciences artificiel aujourd'hui et qui
est dans son coin et qui peut tester le
truc c'est foutu parce que n'a rien de
prêt donc c'est aussi celle qui est
sous-estimée et qui a une probabilité
qui est si j'en crois les experts on y
re non négligeable qu'il y ait un truc
de niveau humain dans un futur pas si
lointain et si c'est le cas il est
mineur
on ne soit pas du tout près donc tout ça
pour dire que rien n'est perdu
je pense qu'il ya encore beaucoup de
recherche qui peut de fait on peut avoir
une structure beaucoup plus solide
beaucoup plus robuste tolérantes aux
fautes et auch n'a pas besoin d'une
morale les yaks tueur parfaite selon lui
pas du tout faut juste qu'elle soit
juste suffisamment bien mais c'est un
problème qui est déjà suffisamment
difficile et qui est absolument pas du
tout près d'être résolu tout cas c'est
l'impression que j'en ai par laure et en
lisant un peu de la recherche dans le
domaine et voilà l'idée que ça pourrait
arriver dans cinq ans ça me fait
vraiment vraiment flippé du coup à
j'aurais tendance à dire que c'est
possible ça se passe bien mais il ya une
probabilité très non négligeable que les
choses se passent mal je pense mais pour
finir sur une note un peu plus jovial se
river fait remarquer que le cinquième
scénario est finalement très proche de
l'idée de la machine de musique dont me
suffit à parler dans cette vidéo dont je
regrette vivement la vidéo de monsieur
fille et ça me fait penser à une
interview d'andorre stenberg qui un
philosophe au cultura open it in situ
créé à oxford et qui parle de
l'hypothèse du prime de fermi du
paradoxe de fermi ce paradoxe il dit que
voilà
là c'est sûr qu'on voit rien qu'on ne
voit pas de vire extraterrestre
intelligente dans l'univers puisqu'a
priori voilà quelques millions d'années
près
forcément s'il n'avait plusieurs univers
y en a une qui serait apparu quelques
millions d'années avant nous alors eu le
temps de se développer et de devenir
énorme et du coup on devrait l'avoir vu
est une explication et qu'avant sa
dorsale berck que je trouve assez
amusante pas entièrement convaincante
les thunder il lui même dit que lui
attribue une probité de 10 % 10 % ce qui
est négligeable
c'est le fait que c'est toutes les
civilisations de futures ont fini par
comprendre que ils ont exploré un peu
l'univers n'avait que l'univers était
cool mais si on finit par comprendre que
le truc le plus cool en fait donc
explorer ce sont les univers virtuels ce
sont des simulations ce sont les
propriétés des puissances de calcul sur
du jeu vidéo clé ça comme vous voulez
mais que du coup pour pouvoir jouer pour
pouvoir profiter de ça le plus longtemps
possible
il fallait faire des calculs qui ont un
coût énergétique le plus faible possible
hélas ce qui est intéressant c'est qu'il
ya une loi de la physique qu'on appelle
le principe de lindau qui dit que en
fait le shaq calculs chaque opération
qui ont effectué en fait ce serait une
opération irréversible mais bon chaque
opération à lison à un coût énergétique
on perd un petit peu d'énergie à
effectuer un calcul et ce qui est
amusant c'est que l'énergie que l'on
perd dépend de la température l'énergie
en fait proportionnelle à température et
ça ça veut dire que si on veut pouvoir
faire beaucoup de calculs avec une
énergie données il vaut mieux faire ce
calcul à une température très basse
or a priori comme en avait à cause de
l'expansion de l'univers
l'univers sera beaucoup beaucoup plus
froid mais dispose ans trente fois plus
froid dans un univers très très très
très très éloigné du coup peut-être que
la stratégie optimale pour
une civilisation indienne qui veulent
juste profiter du calcul autant que
possible ce sera de figer un peu de se
figer au fuji un peu la mémoire de ses
habitants pendant tout l'âge de
l'univers pendant des google d'année et
après des google d'années ils pourront
commencer à faire des calculs dans un
univers qui sera une température de 10
puissance moins 3 montrant kevin quelque
chose comme ça et grâce à cela ils
pourront faire beaucoup beaucoup plus de
calculs que s'il avait commencé les
calculs dès aujourd'hui et ça ça
expliquerait pourquoi les civilisations
un alien cherche à nous avoir aucun
impact dans l'univers d'aujourd'hui
puisque avoir un impact dans l'univers
d'aujourd'hui correspond à dépenser
cette énergie en calcul dans un univers
qui est encore relativement chaud y
compris dans le vide interstellaire et
du coup c'est pas du tout une stratégie
optimale et donc si on peut imaginer que
si toutes les civilisations aliens
finissent par comprendre ça et du coup
se prépare pour une une avenir pas très
lointain
elles chercheront du coup un avoir aucun
impact sur l'univers très proche et
cherchant le juste un agrégé un maximum
de matière c'est conserver la matière
est-ce que la matière et de l'énergie
aussi proches que possible pour pouvoir
une certaine venir dépenser cette
matière dans quelques google jeune et je
trouve ça assez fou comme pensée ouais
pas forcément ultra réaliste mais pas
forcément ultra débile non plus j'espère
que vous avez aimé cette vidéo excelsa
fait notamment réfléchir à la notion
d'altruisme efficaces font ce qu on est
beaucoup à vouloir que le monde se porte
mieux qu'il ne se porte aujourd'hui
mais pour pouvoir y arriver il y est
important d'essayer de saisir
d'identifier notamment les opportunités
les façons de faire pour vraiment
amélioré significativement le monde et
pas pour avoir juste l'impression
d'avoir fait une bonne action
d'ailleurs toute la preuve de cette
vidéo et est fortement influencée par
l'excellent podcasts et issa zone hours
que j'ai cru télé crochet binge écouter
au cours des dernières semaines c'est
vraiment vraiment excellent jeu
2 vivement si vous êtes à l'aise avec
l'anglais je recommande très très très
très vivement d'écouter ce podcast et ça
va vous donner une perspective
complètement différente sur les
problèmes de société
on se rend compte quand on écoute ce
podcast qu'il ya des problèmes
ultra chaud par exemple les robots
autonomes tu as acquis smic sont
vraiment flipper mais aussi d'autres
problèmes comme par exemple la sécurité
et en intelligence artificielle qui sont
des sujets vraiment les gens d'haïti
thousand words les gens interviewés
notamment sont tous des experts qui ont
énormément réfléchi à la question de
l'altruisme efficace comment faire un
maximum de biens en travaillant
aujourd'hui de façon assez concrète est
vraiment ce qu'il reçoit constamment de
ces discussions mais vraiment quasiment
à chaque fois c'est le problème de du
danger de l'intelligence artificielle et
c'est pour ça que je pense que c'est
très très important
si vous avez les compétences notamment
si vous êtes à l'aise avec certaines
notions techniques ou si vous êtes aussi
à l'aise dans les relations si vous avez
un réseau si vous êtes capable
d'influencer les gens qui vont
influencer les décisions
je pense que c'est très important que si
vous voulez fait en plus faire quelque
chose de bien
votre vie entre travail plutôt qu'avoir
un travail où on va juste un employé
classique et en fait on compterait une
certaine manière par exemple à
l'algorithme de youtube je sais juste
maximiser le nombre de vues qui est un
objectif qui est finalement pas si
différent de maximiser les trombones si
vous sentez une petite crise morale et
vous dit peut-être essayer de faire des
trucs
davantage mieux écouter vraiment et qui
s'attend à voir ses premiers pas puis
s'ils voulaient vraiment hollande y
vivent ou prendre il ya des carrières
possibles dans ce genre de domaine
souvent sa demande quelques sacrifices
forcément individuellement notamment au
niveau salarial mais il ya beaucoup de
récompenses aussi puisque là vous aurez
vraiment l'impression de contribuer à ce
que l'on vive dans une meilleure société
ce qui est je pense avec quelque chose
d'assez haut rang on a besoin de
beaucoup plus de main-d'oeuvre beaucoup
plus de gens qui sont capables de bien
réfléchir à ces problèmes est de fournir
des solutions à tous ces problèmes
si vous avez aimez cette vidéo pensez à
la ligue et à la commenter à la partager
pensez à vous abonner pour ne pas
manquer les futurs épisodes version
people power dont et j'espère que vous
serez là la prochaine fois qu est ce qui
est intéressant dans la proche
conséquentialiste c'est que la question
morale fondamentale n'est plus la
question
que dois-je faire mais la question que
vous louez qu'elle l'objectif visons
nous pour le monde sauf à